ganz anderen Thema zu einem
Einfamilienhauses ein Tatort wurde zu
einem unfassbaren Verbrechen zwei Jahre
lang war die kleine pailey verschwunden
verschwunden spurlos verschwunden die
Polizei konnte sie nicht finden die
eigenen Eltern wussten nicht wo sie ist
und in diesem grausamen Versteck wurde
die mittlerweile sechs Jahre alte Paley
gefunden die Täter sind offenbar die
eigenen Eltern
ein Tipp aus der Nachbarschaft für die
Ermittler in das Haus des Großvaters der
kleinen Pacy vor Ort finden die Beamten
die sechsjährige zusammengepfercht mit
ihrer Mutter hier in diesem
Geheimversteck unter der Treppe das
Drama beginnt im Sommer 2019 Kim Cooper
und kirkshow this verlieren das
Sorgerecht für ihre beiden Töchter
Paisley und ihre ältere Schwester die
Gründe hierfür sind bisher noch nicht
bekannt am Tag als die Behörden die
beiden Kinder abholen wollen tauchen
Cooper und schottest mit paisy ab die
ältere Tochter lassen sie zurück sie
flüchten von Caillou geheizt in 210 km
entfernte shoggo TV dort lassen Sie die
damals Vierjährige verschwinden
jahrelang nach bereits mehreren
Einsätzen der Cops in dem Haus fällt
einem Polizisten plötzlich eine
Unstimmigkeit an der Treppe auf endlich
ist die Suche nach Paisley erfolgreich
Bildreporter Herbert baunebel ist nach
schockerties gereist und berichtet
exklusiv die Polizei sagt dass das Kind
jetzt nicht das verwahrlost oder
abgemagert gewesen wäre das das größte
Problem war dass sie einfach nicht
hinaus durfte denn sie wurde ja
versteckt von ihren Eltern und man sieht
doch hier diesen Spielplatz sein
eigentlich sehr großes Spielplatz am
Grundstück des Hauses des Großvaters auf
diesem Spielplatz offensichtlich hat die
kleine Basel nie gespielt aufgefallen
ist auch dass sie keine Schulbildung
hatte dass sie wieder lesen noch
schreiben konnte weil offensichtlich die
Eltern sie nicht unterrichtet haben das
Ganze hatte zweieinhalb Jahre gut
funktioniert denn mehrmals war die
Polizei da gewesen und immer wieder
wurde das kleine Mädchen in diesem
kleinen versteckten Raum gebracht jetzt
der Beginn für Sie eine neue Zukunft bei
neuen Pflegeeltern offensichtlich die
Eltern wie auch der Großvater sind
angeklagt wegen mehrerer Vergehen es
droht ihnen eine Haftstrafe klar ist
natürlich dass dieses Kind offenbar
wahrscheinlich nie wieder zu ihren
leiblichen Eltern zurückkehren darf
und fassbarer Fall dauert der sich in
den USA abgespielt hat das Mädchen das
jahrelang verschwunden war und
gekidnappt wurde von den eigenen Eltern